have a really good business plan um  landlords are are i mean they're they're  cautious anyway  but as a from a landlord perspective  they want to see  that you've really thought this out and  that you have the wherewithal  um both as a business person but also  financially  to get the business open and off the  ground to the point where it's  profitable  and and be able to pay rent so have your  financial statements together and all of  that information  really understand what your costs are um  take a deep look and and what your  operating expenses will be moving  forward  you want to have a good plan in place  and and as a business person you want to  have that for yourself as well because  you want to mitigate your own risk too  so  i mean those are things we do in any  time but even more so right now while  people are being  extra cautious as they should be